bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 débat
sécuriser l'espace public c'est le défi
des systèmes de vidéoprotection
anciennement appelée vidéosurveillance
est difficile d'y échapper en france le
nombre de caméras sur la voie publique a
fortement augmenté ces dernières années
un outil plébiscité mais qui fait débat
quelle en est l'efficacité installer des
caméras est il utile quant aux libertés
individuelles que ce dispositif
interpelle comment concilier alors
sécurité et respect de la vie privée
jusqu'où peut-on aller c'est le débat du
jour et en plateau ce soir avec nous
pierre déjean président de la fédération
des yvelines de la ligue des droits de
l'homme et bernard meyer adjoint à la
sécurité de la ville de plaisir bonsoir
à tous les deux d'une unv nul sur ce
plateau pour commencer ce débat je me
tourne vers vous bernard meyer la vie de
plaisirs est doté d'un système de
vidéoprotection
plusieurs sites sont équipées de caméras
c'est la conséquence de divers incidents
qui vous ont conduit à mettre en place
ce dispositif ou bien de la simple
prévention
d'abord il ya une forte demande de la
part de la population déjà à l'époque un
certain nombre d'incidents pour avoir
une traçabilité de ce tissu et puis
aussi une dissuasion
lorsque vous avez un oeil qui vous
regardent vous savez très bien que ça
vous calme rapidement tout rapidement a
donc c'est effectivement un besoin qui
remonte déjà à la mandature précédente
c'est là le maire précédent qui a mis
100 places avec son équipe et
aujourd'hui madame le maire également
poursuivi dans une volonté de
déploiement mais c'est pas une volonté
de madame amer c'est une volonté des
plaisirs ou à travers les réunions que
nous faisons nous vous passons je passe
aussi pas mal de temps sur le terrain
elle a discuté avec tout le monde il ya
des besoins il ya des demandes
direct à des actes a déjà acquis puis il
ya une à deux joints de tranquillité de
un peu plus de sérénité
et puis de traçabilité bien évidemment
lorsqu'il peut y avoir des incidents qui
se produisent
sachant que les gens des difficultés
bien souvent à faire la démarche à
remonter les informations directement
auprès du commissariat
alors aujourd'hui on parle de vidéo
protection intelligente
le conseil départemental des yvelines a
décidé de doter d'ici 2019 la quasi
totalité de son territoire
deux caméras nouvelle génération et ce
sera une première fois un département
capable de détecter automatiquement un
incident et à ce sujet je vous propose
d'écouter karl olive tree vice président
du conseil départemental investissement
de 13 millions dans les 116 collèges du
département dans les casernes de
pompiers notamment tout simplement pour
créer une plate forme mutualisée d'image
de vidéoprotection dans un espèce de
maillage de logiciels robotisée qui fait
que des cures un moule devant un
mouvement de foule dans tous ces
endroits se sera directement
opérationnels dans ce centre de
supervision urbain efficacité réactivité
aujourd'hui dans le pays en état
d'urgence ce qui est nécessaire
évidemment c'est la réactivité par
rapport à des incidents de plus ou moins
grande importance
r déjà je me tourne vers vous et on va
réagir opérations de surveillance et
terrorisme faire le lien vous vous dites
que c'est un leurre tout à fait c'est un
leurre d'abord les
le système qui est annoncé c'était un
peu annoncé comme le sirop typhon qui
déraille qui garantissait que toutes les
maladies
là on nous parle d'eux
née lloret faire diminuer le terrorisme
la délinquance et les incivilités trois
choses pour lesquelles il fut tellement
il faut lutter mais ce qu'ils ne sont
pas de même nature
donc je vais d'abord qu'on sépare les
choses ensuite le système qui nous est
annoncé et 10 de caméras intelligentes
alors je peux battre sur les caméras ou
si c'est en arrière boutique sur des
ordinateurs mais l'intelligence en
question jusqu'à preuve du contraire
elle n'existe pas nous trois ici nous
sommes des êtres intelligents doué cas
de raisonnement capables de construire
des idées bonnes ou mauvaises ça c'est
autre chose mais une caméra un
ordinateur lui est absolument incapable
de faire ça ce que nous cache avec cela
c'est que derrière il ya des hommes
animés de bonne ou de mauvaise intention
ça c'est encore quelque chose qu'elle
est terminée mais il ya des hommes qui
ont programmé cela est donc ce ne sont
pas les ordinateurs et caméras qui
auraient éventuellement ou une vue
objective
surtout pour les caméras mais ce sont
des hommes qui sont tout à fait
subjectif et qui vont programmer selon
leur système de pensée sans rien
demander à personne
en plus ces caméras alors en plus de
nouvelle génération là je sais pas
exactement ce que ça veut dire mais je
le disais tout à l'heure un article qui
doit dater 2012 2013 par là donc depuis
les
les systèmes ont fait des progrès et qui
disait que les caméras étaient capables
de lire un texto à 200 m donc voyez
c'est pas quelque chose d'anodin c'est à
dire que c'est une surveillance
généralisée de tout le monde et il y
avait aucune liberté aucune vie privée
possible avec cela bernard ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça sur la halle les
termes employés sur plus de liberté avec
l'installation de ceux de ses
dispositifs de vidéoprotection
oui enfin gérer le le sujet très
intéressant mais tout dépend de ce que
l'on va en faire je vous rejoins
également si c'est effectivement pour
aller jusqu à lire les textos à 200 m
c'est une atteinte insupportable pour la
liberté des individus
on retrouve également je préfère
minority report qu'on a tous vu à keita
qui est extrêmement marquant et qui est
grave dans l'évolution de la société
mais de reconnaître via facebook vous
savez qu'on peut il à facebook
enregistré les images les mettre sur le
réseau et ses réseaux de caméras soi
même de vous identifier dans la rue
aujourd'hui
ça existe donc tout dépend effectivement
et je vous rejoins de dire quelles sont
les limites qu'il faut mettre dans
l'exploitation de ces deux systèmes
intelligents et il ya des cas de figure
où il est très important il serait très
important je mets cela inconditionnels
de pouvoir reconnaître identifier des
personnes qui peuvent être derrière à
connotation terroriste qui sont dans une
foule et qu'ils peuvent commettre un
attentat alors que dans certains cas si
on parle d'incivilité leur parle de on
peut trouver ça sur dans la plupart des
villes des vols à la tire d un certain
nombre d'incivilités lourde mais ne
porte pas atteinte à la sécurité
physique des personnes
on n'a pas besoin de systèmes au suis
aussi évoluer un bien évidemment donc il
est bien important également de sérier
l'utilisation de ces types de caméras et
de bien les mettre en place ce
dispositif en fonction des besoins
et justement est-ce que la
vidéoprotection a fait des concrètes à
des résultats concrets pour la ville de
plaisir
oui bien évidemment e
je souhaitais pas douter j'ai je vais
citer qu'elles il ya comme dans toutes
les villes de france et nord je vais pas
dire les petits villages qui n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas de caméra ça nous a
permis d'intervenir sur des trafics de
des trafics de stupéfiants à 2 parce que
vous avez des écrans puisqu'il permet
d'intervenir relativement rapidement
ça se fait je dirais de façon marginale
l'objectif étant de récupérer les images
et de laisser à la police et aux
stupéfiants
le temps de remonter les filières et de
faire les uns des identifications
oui bien évidemment et lorsqu'il ya
également des incidents des gens qui
partent après avoir percuté des
véhicules et étaient donc les i need
anti fication qui permet de reconnaître
le véhicule d'avoir une traçabilité pour
que les assurances puissent faire leur
travail car des gens sur c'est ce que
vous êtes d'accord vous partagez cet
avis sur cette utilisation
oui c'est un peu un peu toujours ce que
l'on dit moi j'attends toujours la
grande étude qui va effectivement nous
montrer l'efficacité
or jusqu'à présent c'était n'a pas eu
lieu en tout cas de grande ampleur dans
ce qui y est
la résolution des délits 10 minutes à
trouver les je crois que ça doit agir à
peu près sur les études partielles qui
ont été faites sur 3 % des cas c'est à
dire un film c'était trois fois rien
alors ce revenir ce qui nous préoccupe
c'est à dire le développement annoncé
par monsieur bédié sur le département
13 millions 13 millions d'euros oui
enfin sauf que j'y mettrai un bémol
d'abord parce que ces 13 millions pour
commencer pour les 4000 caméra je vais
plupart fait le calcul mais ça me paraît
déjà pour faire mais peu importe
mais il faut pour le document pas pour
les 4000 pour les deux premières ils
veulent l'étendre à quatre mille caméras
et à ce nombre de 13 millions ça ne
concerne que l'investissement en
admettant qu'il s'agisse improbable que
l'investissement mais derrière il ya les
contrats de maintenance
il ya les immeubles il ya le personnel
tout ça donc c'est quelque chose qu'on
attendait simplement vous le savez bien
sûr les premières caméras de vidéo
surveillance n'ont pas protection mais
surveillance en faut bien faire
attention aux termes il s'agit de
surveiller pas de protéger les premières
caméras de vidéo surveillance ont été
installées à l'ol a opéré une ville le
bien connu
qui n'a pas fait diminuer le la
délinquance puisque son maire monsieur
balkany est un récidiviste de la
délinquance mais le budget en quatre ans
a augmenté de 80% 80% et donc alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait plus de
prévention est ce qu'il faudrait plus de
deux terrains de deux personnes sur le
terrain plutôt que de ces dispositifs de
vidéoprotection et j'en entends penser
oui moi je dirais cette analyse de d2 il
faut davantage de monde sur le terrain
on sait très bien l'importance qu'il y a
de pouvoir remonter l'information ou
apaisé on va dire une situation en ayant
des policiers police municipale on va
pas revenir sur les polices de proximité
mais également lorsque vous avez une
caméra qui vous fine
nous avons également sur plaisir équiper
la police municipale de caméras que les
policiers peuvent porter donc c'est un
accord de la préfecture
ça calme immédiatement l'agressivité des
personnes qui sont en face et de la part
du côté des policiers qui peuvent
parfois ce sont des hommes comme tout le
monde policier les policières s'emporter
et également de la part des personnes de
je dirais qu'ils sont interpellés ou qui
nécessitent une intervention de la part
des forces de l'ordre donc c'est je
dirais un élément à présent parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya une image une traçabilité
qui est fait on retrouve sur les réseaux
sociaux des vidéos qui sont prises par
tout un ensemble de personnes des
délinquants potentiels des jantes qui se
vante de mettre ces vidéos il n'y a pas
de retour
là il ya un retour à savoir attention
nous avons ces vidéos que personne les
policiers n'ont pas accès à ses débuts
elle sont elles sont stockées ou
qu'elles sont utilisées à quel moment on
peut se servir de ces vidéos jusqu'à
uniquement si effectivement un acte
délictueux qui ai commis donc c'est ça
s'apaise il ya obligation de la part du
policier d'informer la personne en face
nous filmons
le mot de la fin ça sera pour vous oui
bah écoutez je crois que ce débat mérite
encore bien d'autres débats parce que
bien souvent quand on regarde les
émissions télévisées et lorsque je parle
des grandes chaînes bien entendu il ya
un bourrage de crâne on peut appeler ça
comme ça
sur la vidéo surveillance qui serait
effectivement la panacée à tous nos maux
or ce n'est pas comme en vidéo sur wii
bien sûr c'est chez de vidéosurveillance
brother is watching you un désert well
tout à fait c'est ça c'est ça oui donc
en fait c'est quelque chose qui ne
servent pratiquement rien qui pique sa
manchette qui intrusif tout le monde le
sait est bon s'il est s'il y avait
effectivement de vrais débats et non pas
un bourrage de crâne je crois que les
gens changerait un peu d'opinion parce
que ils verraient que le veut le jeu
n'en vaut pas la chandelle
c'est pas une piste technique mois quand
la ratp surveille un escalator avec une
caméra ça ne me dérange pas c'est pas de
ça dont il s'agit c'est bien de
l'intrusion dans la vie privée des gens
pierre déjean bernard meyer merci à tous
les deux d'être venu sur ce plateau fin
du set 8 débat ce soir consacré à la
vidéo protection dans les espaces
publics l'émission est à vous voir sur
notre site internet et a commenté sur
les réseaux sociaux
bonne soirée et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]